hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
clinimax prodigy adherent cell culture
system
pluripotent stem cell expansion and
differentiation in an automated closed
system
presented by dr chow shang i am tracey s
and martin of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by miltny biotek
for more information on our sponsor
please visit miltneybiotech.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask
box located on the far left of your
screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
dr
chow shang the product manager of
regenerative medicine at milne biotech
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr shang
you may now begin your presentation
okay so many thanks for our host
also hello everyone from my side welcome
to this webinar from
milton bel tech actually we are very
glad today
to have this great opportunity to
present you our latest
technologies to automate gmp compliant
propotent stem cell expansion and the
differentiation processes
in a closed system my name is xiao xing
and i'm the product manager for the
regenerative medicine portfolio at
milton bel tech
so we really hope that the technologies
and the results we showed you today
could facilitate your projects
okay so this is the disclaimer for my
presentation today
okay so at the beginning i would like to
briefly introduce you a few key facts
about milton ebeltech especially in the
cell manufacturing field
well you probably know that we were
funded in 1989
and then in 2002 we opened our gmp
manufacturing facility in tetro germany
and 10 years later we further launched
the climax strategy
as a next generation platform for
commercial skills on manufacturing
and based on the climax prodigy platform
in 2016
we released the t-cell transduction
system for car t-cell manufacturing
and then one year later we further
opened our
miltonia biotech cell factory at our
headquarter in germany
and also in sunnyvale california as
grand gmp
some manufacturing facilities to serve
our customers
so in the last 30 years we have gained
extensive experiences in the
semi-manufacturing field
however we have never and we will never
stop our exploration in science and
technologies
so this brings us to today's topic stem
cells
and regenerative medicine so first
maybe let's first have a look at the
development of the car t
therapies that in this field i think we
could very easily go back to
20 years ago but the real turning point
we believe
was in 2002 when the first impatient
car t treatment was proved very
successful and then the entire field was
very encouraged
and the numbers of car t therapy trials
also started to increase
exponentially worldwide in line with
this global trend
in 2016 we launched the climax strategy
t-cell transaction system
for automated and cost-effective car
t-cell manufacturing
since then the prodigy platform has been
very readily used in many car t research
and clinical applications meanwhile our
max quant analyzer
and the title sales alter also showed
their grid values for the in-process
control
quality control analysis as well as cell
sorting procedures
in carti applications so now
let's think loudly and shape our
attention
to the regenerative field as we all
probably
already witnessed in recent years it
also has become a key global focus
the number of stem cells especially
those
potent stem cell-based clinical trials
are increasing
every year so the pse derived functional
somatic cells
have already been transplanted into the
patients
for the treatment of muscular
degeneration
parkinson's disease spinal cord injuries
cardiac diseases etc well of course
we would have to wait and see the
clinical data from these trials but
many people including us believe that
these pfc-based clinical trials
these plc therapies will show their
great values their
great potentials in upcoming years
however despite the big potentials well
currently
gmt compliant cost effective and also
scalable
ps plc manufacturing still remains
a major challenge for their clinical
applications
therefore we have made a lot of effort
actually in the last few years
to try to transfer our expertise from
the cartesian infection field
into the region into the regional
medicine applications
and have developed a number of new
technologies on the prodigy
and max quant for complex
adherent stem cell expansion
differentiation as well as
ipc qc assays
well these are certainly not easy tasks
as we are facing many challenges in this
field
but first let's look at the major steps
of
pse applications in particular
for regenerative medicine clinical
applications
i think i mean the first step would be
normally
to qualify donors and derive somatic
cells from them
and then establish multiple ipsc cell
lines
with very stringent ipc qc procedures
here we also know that
in some trials and countries embryonic
stem cells
will also be used so all these psc lines
needs to be established
very closely following the local
regulations
next step the qualified psc lines needs
to be also expanded
to establish master and working cell
banks
at last efficient differentiation sops
also have to be developed to generate
the desired cell types in cell
populations
for the downstream applications
well there are many important
requirements for these region medicine
clinical applications
among them there are a few essential
requirements
for example the whole manufacturing
processes
have to be gmp-compliant and the
manufactured sops also have to be
scalable and reproducible at the same
time
to make the final cell product
affordable to the patients
and to the health care system the
manufacture and quality control
processes also have to be very cost
effective
to for all these reasons manufacturing
stem cell products for region medicine
applications
is such a challenging and complex
endeavor
well to fulfill all these essential
requirements
most of the current manufacturing
processes involve
multiple expensive and complex
instruments
very skilled operators and high class
clean rooms
many separated and also open handling
steps are also introduced
into these workflows meanwhile standard
in-process control and quality control
assays
are always required throughout the whole
process
well all these factors together could
really limit
the manufacturer's skill compromise the
reproducibility
at the same time significantly drive up
the production cost
so everyone in this field is facing the
same question
how to make these very complex cell
manufacturing processes
more standardized scalable at the same
time also more affordable for the end
users
well the solutions from milton bel tech
are presented here so these are our
automated enclosed
cell manufacturer solutions with the
clean max prodigy
the separated open handling steps
multiple devices
as well as skilled personnel and high
class clean rooms
can be integrated into one automated
and closed platform
and on top of that the users could also
very flexibly
build customized proponent stem cell
expansion and differentiation processes
on the prodigy platform this is based on
this
brand new climax prodigy adherent cell
culture system
and now i will just very briefly walk
you through
both the hardware and software features
of this new system
on cleanmax prodigy
okay so let's start with a short video
so that you could get some very direct
impressions
about this new system how the
tyrannosaur culture system works
and what are the advantages in
comparison to the conventional manual
processes
manufacturing adherent cells such as
pluripotent stem cells and their
derivatives
or mesenchymal stromal cells to gmp
standards is a challenging
endeavor it involves open and complex
manual handling steps
and requires multiple devices high class
clean rooms and
well-trained operators production
capacity is limited
complications can compromise
reproducibility
and significantly increase manufacturing
costs
we at milne biotech are bringing our
expertise to the field of regenerative
medicine
to address these challenges relying on
our widely used
clinimax prodigy cell manufacturing
platform
we have developed the adherent cell
culture system
it realizes reliable safe and
cost-effective manufacturing of adherent
cell types in a closed system
the adherent cell culture system
consists of nine modules
that automate the individual steps of
adherent stem cell expansion
and differentiation processes
by combining selections of these modules
even complex workflows
such as expansion and directed
differentiation of pscs can be realized
using the touch screen the operator can
easily set up processes
whilst maintaining control of the
details
this offers a high degree of flexibility
without compromising consistent
processes
with the clinimax prodigy adherent cell
culture system
hands-on time is significantly reduced
a good example is the density gradient
centrifugation module
during msc manufacturing it can reduce
the manual handling time for bone marrow
mononuclear cell isolation by up to 90
percent
in addition reduced operator influence
minimizes product variability
the cell manufacturing process takes
place in the fully closed
and gmp compliant tubing set with
minimal
open handling steps and reduced clean
room requirements
external culture vessels can be easily
connected to the tubing set via sterile
welding
enabling cell manufacturing at a large
scale
as a result the clinimax prodigy
adherent cell culture system
offers a flexible platform for gmp
compliant manufacturing of various
adherent cell types
with the clinimax prodigy adherent cell
culture system
manufacturing adherent cell products to
gmp standards
is not only easier and safer but also
more cost effective
break the limits and overcome the
challenges
of manufacturing adherent cell types
let's start the conversation today
miltoni
biotech
okay so with this short video probably
now you have some first impressions
in mind now let's start with the core
hardware
this functionally integrated climax
prodigy platform
together with the disposable and gmp
compliant tubing set
and other important units and
accessories
the climax prodigy system allows
automated self processing
from starting materials to the final
products upon your request
it could handle all these processes and
steps
including sample preparation density
grading certification
so washing medium change etc all the way
until final product formulation
one of the most important hardware
features of this new
adherence or culture system is that cell
cultivation can take place
in two different units the central code
unit
and the external cultural vessels first
the central unit well you can see
probably on the upper part
there's a climax prodigy chamber lies
inside
the centricle unit or so-called ccu for
short
so which is hard the heart of for for
the salmon section
well this part supports automated
adherent
and non-appearance cell cultivations so
it works basically as a small incubator
so you could control the temperature
from 4 degree to 38 degree
inside the central unit and also the
concentrations of co2 and
air you could also visualize your cell
cultures because we have integrated
a camera under the chamber there are
also multiple input
multiple input port which are available
to the centric code unit
so that you can supply different medium
or cellular kinds
to your cell cultures this climax
prodigy chamber
offers 100 square centimeter surface
base
well at the same time if larger surface
space and cell numbers are required
then external cartridge vessels can also
be connected
to the kinematics prodigy system where
stereo welding technologies
for example these multi-layer cell
stacks
well i just want to point it out that
when the users are using the external
cultural vessels
then these culture vessels also have to
be kept in an external
incubator for the temperature co2 and
other culture conditions
cultivation in the central unit and
external cultural vessels
are both realized by this gmp-compliant
tubing set
tsm30 which was designed actually
specifically for the attention culture
system
by stereo welding the users can connect
as many bags of medium
buffers reasons reagents as they need
to the system during the manufacture
process as you can see
on the left side there are many long
tubings which are available
on this tubing set so you can weld down
many bags to the tubing set
the target cell bags and the sampling
pouches are also already
integrated into the tubing set so that
the users can very conveniently
passage harvest and quality control
their cells
also as mentioned external culture
vessels can be easily connected
with zero welding for larger scale cell
cultivation
and make these external culture vessels
be part of the closed
max prodigy system the users could
connect
three of these five layer cell stack at
a time
so this will give you roughly 10 000
square centimeter surface space
which is fairly large
these are some of the key hardware
features and now i would like to shift
your attention
to the appearance of culture software
system i think the biggest
challenge that we're facing here is that
there are so many different
adherence cell types such as proportion
stem cells
mesenchymal stromal cells neural cells
and cardinal cells etc and we really
want to make sure that our system is
flexible enough
to cover most of the demands so that is
why
we modularize the individual cell
handling steps
in the system so on the right hand side
you can see that
all these modules lies in the main menu
of the ethereum cell culture system not
only that
the users can combine various modules
in different orders to automate
different cell culture handling steps as
a result
very complex cell cultivation workflows
such as expansion
and directed differentiation of pcs can
be realized
in this prodigy system
coming back to this process scheme that
i introduced you earlier
so now you might already notice that
many of these manual handling steps
such as surface coating resource
inoculation
medium change harvesting etc can also be
can already be reflected
by the different modules in the tyrion
cell culture system
and within each module the users can
also choose between the central
unit and the external cultural vessels
based on your sops or
your culture skills meanwhile the users
can also set up
all the important cultivation parameters
upon your request
this applies to all the modules one
example here
so in a coding module then you can set
up the coating temperature
the coating time the volumes of your
coating reagents
etc all according to or according to
your sops or your protocols
you will also have an overview page in a
summary
in the end so you can confirm the
settings
or reset if you decide to change any
parameters
and our goal here is combining our
widely used
climax prodigy instruments and the gmp
compliant tubing set
the highly flexible adhesion cell
culture software system
the max gmp stem cell culture medium
cytokines small molecules
so we could support the entire so
manufacturing processes
of many different adherence cell types
of course this will include the
proponents themselves
in addition our max clone analyzer and
reaffinity recombinant antibodies
could also support you with automated
and standard
flow cytometry ipcq css throughout the
whole process
now i would like to present you some of
our recent data
from the established pac expansion
and differentiation workflows
following the current leading regional
medicine applications
we first aimed at realizing
gmp-compliant
pac expansion process as well as
efficient differentiation of pses
towards
main brain domain logic progenitors and
cardiomyocytes
in this automated enclosed climax
prodigy adherent cell culture system
first for sino-frey human psc expansion
we have developed two different mediums
so we have the stamx ipc pro
xenofree medium which is a very cost
effective research grade medium
and in this experiment i showed here in
the slide
two ipc clones were expanded for 20
passages
in this medium and we found that the
cells had very stable doubling times
during the long-term cultivation and
using stemx ipsc
boost you know frame medium pscs can be
splitted
as single cells or smart cell clusters
at the same time if you want to
translate your cultural process
to a gmp compliant process well you
could simply switch
to the ipsc blue gmp medium which is a
gmp compliant medium
manufactured following the guidelines of
iso 13485
and the ipc boot jp medium is based on
the same formulation as the research
grade median
so performance wise they give rise to
very comparable results
therefore you will have a very seamless
transition
from a research grade to gmp compliant
human pse expansion workflow
using the max quant analyzer and the
reaffinity
recombinant antibodies for those key per
potency markers
we have developed a multi-color flow
cytometry immunophenotyping protocol
analysis which were done at passage 5 10
15 and 20 showed persistently
high expression levels of those potency
markers
including tri160 ssd4
sdz5 x2 and oct4
and almost no expression of the
different differentiation marker
as u1 trilines differentiation
differentiation potentials of the pses
were accessed
also at passage 5 10 15 and 20
using the samax trial lineage
differentiation kit
which support directed the
differentiation into all three german
layers
based on lineage specific and complete
medium
quantitative flows the temperature
analysis on the max 1
analyzer also confirmed very stable
capacities
of these plcs to differentiate into
mesoderm
endoderm and ectoderm-derived somatic
cells
gmp-compliant psc expansion and standard
flow cytometry qc analysis can be
achieved
manually by very experienced operators
so now the question is
if we can transfer manual psd expansion
into the closed and automated climax
prodigy at humans or culture system
well the answer is yes and we have
summarized
all the technical details in this
application sheet which you can download
directly from our website and i will
show you the link
in the end of the presentation
this is an overview of this
prodigy-based psc expansion process
with the attuned cell culture system you
can select
and combine various modules to automate
all these complex handling steps like i
showed you on the right hand side
for example the coating cell inoculation
medium change self-splating harvesting
etc
and in the end you could use the
tri-lineage differentiation kit
max corner analyzer and reaffinity
recombinant antibodies
for standard flow cytometry quality
control analysis
and to determine the quality of these
proposal stem cells
expanded in the prodigy attenuator
culture system
we have performed side by side
comparisons between manual processes
and prodigy based processes looking at
the
expression levels of those key potency
markers
and also the tri-lineage differentiation
capacities
these two groups really give rise to
very comparable results
at the same time by using the prodigy
chamber and different sizes of the
external cultural vessels for example
one layer sales tag
five-layer sales tax the users can also
very easily reach different culture
skills
and we know that establishing gmp
compliance
master proportion stem cell bank is
always um
you know is is a major step in many
clinical applications
so for this purpose the close and
automated climax prodigy of the
intercultural system
together with the gmp compliant cell
culture medium consumables
could be very valuable for your projects
not only for pse expansion and banking
processes the adherence of culture
system can also automate
very complex pse differentiation
processes
such as midbrain dominologic progenitor
differentiation
and this application has been supported
by a very prestigious
european consortium the neurostem cell
repair consortium
and we have collaborated with dr malin
palmer and dr agnet kirkby
during the development we know that they
have already established very efficient
very optimized protocols to derive sda
progenitors
from human human pscs so the real
challenge for us
is that if we can very precisely adapt
their original manual protocol into this
closed and automated prodigy system
and once again we have successfully
fulfilled this task
so we are and automated this msd
progenitor differentiation process on
the prodigy
all the technical details can be found
in a dedicated application sheets
as well so which you can download from
the the website and i'll show you the
link
in the end i will skip the process
details due to the time limits today
instead i want to show you some side by
side comparison result
between manual and prodigy processes
as i showed in this slide using the
max clone analyzer and the key must
deprotonate markers
such as fox a2 and otx2 the results show
that
the cells that are differentiated on the
climax prodigy is also very comparable
to the cells differentiated manually
with more than 80
of the resulting cells co-expressing the
key
positive massdep markers foxe2 and otx2
nearly no expression of the negative
markers such as pac6
sucks 1 or octa4 and decreased
expression of the proliferation marker
kf67 therefore quality wise
the prodigy system is very well
qualified
the advantages of the prodigy process in
this application
are the closed and gmp compliant
environment as well as the culture
skills
for example starting from one million
proportion stem cells
then after five days pre-expansion and
another 16 days directed differentiation
we could harvest roughly three to four
billion
highly purified mass d8 pro gender cells
which could be
translated to almost 600 to 800 patient
doses
considering 5 million cells per cryo
unit
at the same time as you can also see on
the right hand side
from three individual experiments these
results are also very reproducible
in the itunes cell culture system
except for dominarity progenitors we are
also constantly
developing new applications to
differentiate pscs
into other cell types which are highly
desired in the region medicine
field for example we are currently
developing a psc to cardiomyocyte
differentiation workflow
on climax prodigy and for this we have
first
released developed a sino-frey stamx
cardio differentiation kit which is
already available
for our users this differentiation kit
provides a complete and ready to use
xenophobia cell culture system for
efficient and robust
differentiation of cardiomyocytes the
kit is composed of
three phenol red free medium that
progressively
restrict the cellular fate and specify
the differentiation
into cardiomyocytes in just eight days
of culture
depending on the cell lines that you are
using first contradict contracting
cardiomyocytes can be even observed
only after six days of culture
using this case robust differentiation
can be repeated
across multiple proposed stem cell lines
and the resulting cells also express the
specific cardio
cardiomyocyte markers so these are the
results from the manual process
now currently using the samax cardio
differentiation kit
we are automating the cardiomyocyte
differentiation process
on the claymax prodigy to reach uh
bigger scales we are testing external
cultural vessels
for this process starting with one of
those one layer subtext
now on the uh on this slide you can see
in three individual experiments
we could achieve very robust and
efficient cardinal size differentiation
already
on the prodigy flow cytometry assay
using the maximum analyzer
shows that the differentiation
efficiency can already reach between
eighty to ninety percent so if you are
working with uh
cardi monster differentiation then you
probably know this is actually a quite
decent differentiation efficiency also
we can already harvest roughly 100
to 200 million cardamom cardiomyocytes
from only one of those one-layer cell
stacks
so we are working on further scaling up
this process this workflow
by using larger external cultural
vessels
okay so in the last few minutes i would
like to explain you how
the climax prodigy system could benefit
the regenerative medicine application
we know that most of the proposed stem
cell-based clinical trials are still at
very early phase
however according to the icr guidelines
for clinical trials the stem cell
manufacture sops
used in these trials must be thoroughly
studied
optimized and fixed already at the early
phases
later on you know the later down the
road the less possible actually
to make changes on these manufacturing
sops
therefore the trial leaders also need to
make sure that
their cell manufacturing platforms are
not only suitable for their
early phase development when only small
numbers of patients are involved but
also
can meet the demands at the later phases
when they need to
manufacture gmp-compliant cell products
at bigger scales
so we have already taken these factors
into consideration
and tried to make the climax prodigy
systems
suitable all the way from small scale
process developments
to gmp compliant commercial skill cell
production
so for the process operators who are
working on cell manufacturer on a daily
basis
the prodigy system could really make
their life easier
by reducing the hands-on times the
numbers of open handling steps
and also lowering the failure rate all
in all
it gets easier and safer for the
operators
at the same time for the decision makers
by looking at the major cost drivers of
some manufacturing processes
the climax prodigy system enables
significant cost reduction
in capital cost and labor cost in
details
well already in some countries using the
closed
prodigy system gmp compliant some
infection
can take place in relatively lower class
clean rooms
such as class c then of course the users
have to
closely discuss and confirm this with
their local
regulatory authorities but if this is
the case if this is approved
then this will be a major cost saver for
clean room maintenance
and operations at the same time
automated cell handling steps
also largely reduce needs and cost for
highly trained
operators and training programs
based on our own data and analysis
compared to many based
processes the climax prodigy system
could offer roughly 33 reduction in the
capital cost and 80
85 percent reduction in labor cost and
overall resulting in roughly 40 to 50
reduction in the yearly cost of goods
with the same manufacturing yield
well we think these could be some
interesting information for the decision
makers
in the sound gene therapy field when
they plan when they design
their stem cell manufacturing pipelines
and the clinical application
we are dedicated actually to support the
users at our best
so for the end users of the q max
prodigy athena cell culture system
we provide a very comprehensive training
program
so this is glance of this training
schedule so it is a three days training
programs
including theoretical trainings guided
and unguided hands-on trainings
and also troubleshooting sessions so you
could
visit our website to find more detailed
information there
okay so i think we are almost at the end
of the presentation
i would like to take this opportunity to
acknowledge
our funding resources and also our great
collaborators
so if you want to find more details
about the climax prodigy
adherence our culture system please
click on the the link the upper link
here so to download the scientific
posters
the application sheets of the psc
workflows and
also find more detailed information
about the relevant products
meanwhile if you have some questions or
if you have any interest
in the climax prodigy system you can
click on the lower link
to get in contact with us then we will
try to get back to you
as soon as possible so at last many
thanks for your time and
your attention today so i would be very
happy to
take your questions now
thank you dr shang for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question
is how many pscs can i expand
in this adherent cell culture system
well thanks for the question actually is
a good one
so the users can actually perform pse
expansion at
different skills depending on the
cultural vessels that they're using
so that is why we don't have a definite
maximum
psc expansion skill in this climax
strategy attunes our culture system
so i probably already you can find more
details in my slides
so we have tested uh several different
cultural vessels
for example if you are using the climax
prodigy chamber
which is uh 100 square centimeters then
you could probably culture
up to five times ten to the seven pse's
so based on our own data so if you're
using this one layer
cell sac which has uh 636 square
centimeters
then you could probably go up to uh two
times ten to the eight pses
then if you are using one of those five
data cell stack
which has uh 3180 square centimeters so
fairly large
and there you could probably go up to
even one billion
proportions themselves but also please
keep in mind that
these results are only from our own
experiment so the results are very cell
line dependent
probably you already know because this
is a general feature for the proponent
stem cells
okay next question oh sorry
no problem so we can go on to the next
one
oh yes dr chang um the next question is
will the prodigy affect the flurry
potency properties
of ipscs during the automated expansion
process
well i mean that's also a very important
question so that's why
we have did a lot of experiment we have
did you know we have done
side by side comparisons between the
prodigy process
and the manual process as i also briefly
showed in the presentation so maybe
later
you after the webinar you can go back
and to check the details
so in this presentation we showed the
pse expanded on the prodigy
i mean they also showed very high
expression levels of the key per potency
markers
and they are also able to differentiate
into all three german layers
so at the same time these results are
very comparable
to the manually expanded plc's in our in
our r d lab
can you elaborate on how to connect the
cell stacks to the prodigy and how to
make sure the system is still closed
okay so that's a technical one so uh to
re to connect the cell stack to the
prodigy then you first need to connect
the cell sec
with a very specific cell stack
accessory so which
is is a mpc connector this is actually
already available from also from corning
so you can actually
buy it directly from corning together
with the sales deck
so this celltec mpc connector is very
compliant
with our prodigy accessory such as the 1
meter
1 meter tube extension and the 3-way
adapter
so by using the serial welder the users
can very conveniently
very easily weld on the two tubes
together
so they can connect the cell stack to
the prodigy tubing set
and this sterile welding process
itself it is also a closed process
do i need to change tubing set during
cell passaging
well that's also as it's a very
important question
so in general if the users want to
passage themselves
multiple times during the process we
know this is i mean
for pse this is very important so they
actually
they only need to connect more target
cell bags
and the more external cultural vessels
for each pathogen
so so far our longest workflow is this
proponents themselves to match the
progenitor differentiation process
which takes 21 days in total
so the entire process is carried out in
only one tubing set
cultivation longer than 21 days in one
tubing set
is possible but i think this also needs
to be tested
by the users by the end users for their
own specific applications
thank you dr shang can i use
this prodigy system to differentiate
pscs
into other somatic cell types
yeah actually well the differentiation
into other cells that
might require different medium and
growth factors but as long as the
differentiation process
i mean is adherent and the handlings in
the human sarcoces
might be rather similar thus you know it
is also very likely that
this can be adapted and realized in a
prodigy system
but of course you know we could have i
mean then if you are interested maybe
get in contact with us
and we can have more details more
in-depth discussions
to judge if and how to automate this
required process
on the climax prodigy so if you are
interested please just
you get in contact with us so we would
be happy to
have further discussions with you
okay our next question is how many
cardiomyocytes can be manufactured in
this prodigy system
well um as i mentioned so we are still
working on this cardiomyocyte
differentiation process
at the moment so at the moment the
result shows us
um the psc differentiation on uh the psc
to cardiomyocyte differentiation on the
climax prodigy
using this newly released stemac's
cardio differentiation kit
they're quite robust and efficient based
on the
first experiment we could harvest
roughly
100 to 200 million carbon monoxide
from one of those one layer salt deck
well
and we are further scaling up this
process by using
larger quarter vessels for example we're
trying to use those
five layer cell stacks basically five
times bigger
than the one layer celsac then we're
expecting to have to
you know harvest more carbon monoxide in
the end using larger
external cardiovessels
okay we have time for one more question
the last question for today is how pure
is the dopaminergic progenitor
differentiated on the prodigy
well um this we have done uh
several experiments so we always repeat
our experiment to show that
our process are consistent are
reproducible
so across several differentiation
experiments we could get very consistent
results
for the car for the dominar progenitor
differentiation process
so in the end over 80 percent of the
differentiated
resulting cells co-express the key
uh mesti protein markers fox a2 and odx2
and also there's nearly no expression
for the
unspecific neural lineage markers and
also the pre-potency markers
pack six sucks one and octo four so
these markers were
nearly um undetectable in the end
and we also could observe largely
reduced largely reduced
expression of the proliferation marker
ki-67
in the resulting cell populations so i
would say
in the end the dopaminergic progenitors
differentiate
on the climax prodigy attunes our
cultural system they are quite pure
mastery approach gender populations
thank you again uh dr shang do you have
any final comments for our audience
today
well um actually a very simple i mean
like i already showed in my last slide
so
due to the limit amount of time we
couldn't go we cannot go into all the
details in this presentation
but you you can certainly find more
information about
our established workflows on our on our
website
so there are two links there so with the
upper link then you can download the
scientific posters
or the application sheets and with the
lower link
you can get in contact with us and you
can send us also
your questions thanks a lot for your
attention again
and hope that the this technology would
really
like a hostile will be helpful for your
projects
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
we would like to thank you dr chow shang
for your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye